-Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
You're here.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, earlier today,
President Biden made
a major announcement
that he is banning U.S. imports
of Russian oil,
dealing another huge blow
to Russia's economy.
Yeah, this is devastating
for Russia.
Now their biggest export is
bad guys in "John Wick" movies.
[ Laughter ]
[ Russian accent ] You'll never
get away with this, John Wick.
[ Normal voice ]
Of course, we've got to get oil
from somewhere else,
which is why today Biden looked
at Rudy Giuliani and was like,
"Let's get you in the sauna,
buddy.
Let's go."
[ Laughter ]
"Let's get you
on the treadmill, pal."
That's right, gas prices
were already on the rise,
and with the decision
to ban Russian oil,
they're higher than ever before.
Gas prices are so high,
the Indy 500 was just changed
to the Indy 5.
[ Laughter ]
Gas prices are so high,
this morning, parents were like,
"Alright, kids, we're Amish now.
Let's get in the buggy.
We're taking the horse
to school."
Gas prices are so high,
Americans are just filling
their cars with Red Bull
and hoping for the best.
[ Laughter ]
Listen to this --
According to a new poll,
70% of Americans support a ban
on Russian oil,
even if it means
higher gas prices.
Yeah, then Netflix was like,
"We're also raising our prices
to help Ukraine.
Gonna help Ukraine."
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, in another blow
to their economy,
today, McDonald's announced
that it was closing
all 850 of its restaurants
in Russia.
Yeah, we don't want their oil,
and they can't have our grease.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
Not to be outdone,
Arby's announced
that they are punishing Russia
by staying open.
-Really?
-Yeah.
Yeah, they're open 24/7.
Yeah.
-"We have the meats."
-Yeah, McDonald's --
McDonald's in Russia
is a little strange.
It's the only country
that sells Unhappy Meals.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, gosh.
Yeah.
Just give me the card, yeah.
Can I sign it?
♪♪
Here you go.
How you doing?
There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Just terrible.
I had to do that joke.
Thank you.
Sorry.
"Unhappy Meals."
-Nice. Come on.
-I apologize, everyone.
[ Laughter ]
Some more business news.
Apparently to offset
rising costs,
toilet paper brands are cutting
back on the size of their rolls.
Yeah, whether it's
a global pandemic or a war,
they always have to
make it about them.
[ Laughter ]
It's always about toilet paper.
Yeah, it's not good.
Today at CVS, I saw a package
of Charmin Just Tubes.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-What do you do with it?
Guess they wiped out the supply.
[ Laughter ]
[ Rim shot ]
-You're on a roll.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Well, some TV news --
last night was our favorite
"The Bachelor:
Women Tell All" episode.
And things got pretty heated
after Shanae
called out Genevieve
for hooking up with
a former "Bachelor" contestant.
The show can be
pretty emotional,
so I thought we could help.
Here's the moment re-voiced
with the least emotional person
we know -- Siri.
This is "Let's Get Siri-ous."
-"Let's get Siri-ous."
-After I got eliminated,
I went home.
And then when you
get eliminated,
you bleep Aaron
from Katie's season.
What? What?
Whoa. Oh.
Oh, my God.
Oh, you know what?
You know what's funny? Oh, okay.
I know you've been DM'ing him
and all that.
100%. Go ask him, 'cause I've
never slid in his DMs, honey.
He sent me a screenshot, honey.
I never slid in his DMs.
No.
I've never slid in his DMs.
Ha ha ha ha.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Did you guys hear about this?
Experts are urging NASA
to study sex in space
since it would be essential for
human survival on long journeys.
Yeah, sex in space,
or as Jeff Bezos's rocket
put it, "Way ahead of you."
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, boy.
-And finally, this is amazing.
There's a new therapy
that could actually reverse
the aging process by making
your cells young again.
Yeah, it's crazy.
Soon, people might be able
to go back
to how they looked years ago.
We actually have some examples.
For instance,
here's Bernie Sanders.
And here's Bernie
after reverse aging.
[ Laughter ]
Here's -- Here's Prince Charles.
Yeah, and here he is
after reverse aging.
[ Laughter ]
Up next, here's former
attorney general William Barr.
Yeah, and here he is afterwards.
He's Ralph.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, here's Tom Brady.
And here is Tom Brady
after reverse aging.
Unbelievable.
Guys, we have a great show.